tej bonjour renault a donc annoncé la
mauvaise nouvelle à ses salariés ce
matin c'est ça dort à 15000 dans le
monde 4600 en france c'est le nombre de
postes que devrait supprimer
renault fut une mesure qui s'inscrit
dans le cadre d'un vaste plan
d'économies de 2 milliards d'euros sur
trois ans d'ici à 2024 et cela malgré le
prêt accordé 2 5 milliards d'euros par
l'état français le constructeur a compté
l'an dernier une perte nette de 141
millions d'euros une première depuis dix
ans les capacités de production du
groupe au niveau mondial vont donc être
réduite de 4 passant de 4 millions de
véhicules à 3,3 millions de véhicules à
l'avenir plusieurs sites vont donc être
fermés on parle de ceux de dieppe caudan
de choisy le roi et un peu plus tard
celui de flins choisy-le-roi où se sont
réunis un derrière moi une centaine de
salariés qui a manifestent contre
justement ce plan de restructuration
alors même si la direction promet qu'il
n'y aura aucun licenciement sec et que
les départs se feront de manière
volontaire ou sur des reconversions
beaucoup de salariés à s'inquiète pour
en parler nous sommes avec jean-françois
un bail députés aient l'air au m2 du val
de marne bonjour merci d'être avec nous
alors peut-être un mot sur ces annonces
et cette fermeture et si du site de
choisy le roi écoutez c'est une annonce
qui nous a aujourd'hui extrêmement
choqué et bouleversé on est abasourdi il
n'y a pas de mots pour décrire
aujourd'hui le sentiment de gâchis qui
est en train d'être opéré sentiment de
gâchis qui est pour le coup là aussi
énormément soutenu et énormément au
relais par là la centaine de salariés
par les élus que nous sommes
j'ai moi même
puis maintenant une semaine fede des
déclarations demandé à ce que l'état
puisse revoir un petit peu ce plan
d'économies qui est proposé par renault
on a bien conscience que les difficultés
renault ne date pas de maintenant
mais quel gâchis aujourd'hui de se
passer de ce site vous savez cet
incident qui est là depuis 70 ans
maintenant c'est un maillage sur le
territoire extrêmement important avec
des plans de formation une
responsabilité environnementale sociale
qui n'est plus à démontrer que vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure on fait quand
même ici de l'économie circulaire à
l'heure où on nous parle de changement
de politique en matière de développement
durable
c'est extrêmement bouleversant écoeurant
je dirais même dans l'arrivée à 7 à
cette disparition de cette de cette
usine
l'état a fait ce qu'il fallait pour
sauver cette entreprise selon moi je
crois que l'état aujourd'hui doit
prendre sa part de responsabilité en
tant qu'actionnaire du groupe renault
monté un petit peu plus j'irai au
créneau pour sauver l'économie
circulaire de de ce site
encore une fois chacun prêche pour sa
paroisse moi je suis ici député du val
de mende et de cette circonscription
évidemment que je prêche d'abord aussi
pour ma paroisse pour ce site auquel je
suis extrêmement attachée et qui va
malheureusement être délocalisée à flins
pour moi c'est un gâchis
c'est un non sens c'est une aberration
c'est incohérent avec tout ce que l'état
a pu mettre en terme de pâques et
financiers pour sauver un petit peu le
groupe industriel renault
vous faites partie de la majorité
présidentielle et ça ne vous empêche pas
d'avoir des désaccords notamment avec
bruno le maire le ministre de l'econo je
suis sur ce dossier je suis extrêmement
désaccord avec le ministre de l'économie
effectivement sur ce qui a pu être fait
parce que je considère que une usine qui
chaque année sort entre 40000 boîte
moteur entre 39 mille boîtes de vitesses
qui sont reconditionnés qui sont
réemployés
il est aberrant aujourd'hui de procéder
à une fermeture
de cette usine de m aussi je fumais qui
seront ainsi sur le carreau 265 salariés
et 265 salariés je ne compte pas les
intérimaires qui travaillent pour moi
c'est une aberration et c'est quelque
chose que moi je m'oppose fermement à
cette à cette manière de faire l'état
français perd la france perd beaucoup
aujourd'hui le notre territoire perd
beaucoup
déjà le territoire du val de marne perd
beaucoup la ville de choisy le roi perd
énormément c'est une ville qui était une
ville industrielle ou pratiquement
toutes les entreprises industrielles
parts sont délocalisés et donc ça doit
aujourd'hui nous nous faire réfléchir à
comment est ce qu'on leur prépare mais
pardon choisy le roi dans un projet de
territoire avec des industries voix l'a
annoncé c'est une énorme perte est un
énorme gâchis pour notre territoire qui
est inconcevable qui est incohérent avec
tout ce qui est menée jusqu'à présent
est de toute façon tout ce qui est
l'avenir l'avenir de l'économie
je crois que l'économie passe aussi par
une économie circulaire ah bah tant
mieux
ici c'est de l'économie circulaire qu'on
fait c'est un maillage qui est là encore
une fois c'est un plan de formation avec
le greta qui est pas très loin avec pôle
emploi avec des lycées techniques vous
avez un lycée technique à créteil le
lycée technique de branly qui est en
partenariat avec avec cette usine a donc
franchement c'est moi je suis en colère
je suis en colère aujourd'hui de voir
que on est capable de se passer d'un
fleuron comme ça dans dans une ville et
dans un département comme le nôtre dans
une ville comme choisy le roi une
entreprise qui se porte d'air c'est
ainsi qu'ils se portent très bien
financièrement donc évidemment c'est un
sentiment de colère
jean-françois un bail merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes député la république en marche
du val de marne donc vous l'avez entendu
un jean françois bay qui est bien fichu
une certaine colère une certaine
amertume avec l'annoncé de cette
fermeture aujourd'hui de ce site de
choisy le roi jean françois humbert qui
fait partie de la majorité
présidentielle et qui elle n'a pas
hésité qui n'hésite pas à afficher
certains désaccords qu'il a avec
du coup le ministre de l'économie et son
positionnement au sujet de ce dossier
remis un adage abderrazak merci pour
toutes ces précisions